há 27 por cento das universitárias já
foram vítimas de violência contra mulher
trata-se de uma violência de gênero nós
não estamos falando de um assalto ou de
um furto mas meu vai lá em São motivada
exclusivamente pela vítima ser uma
mulher retrato mais perverso das
relações de poder e desigualdade entre
homens e mulheres Eliete saffioti um dos
grandes nomes nos estudos de gênero
ainda na década de 60 dizia que a
violência contra a mulher tem origem os
papéis desiguais entre homens e mulheres
quem são esses os papéis que definem os
comportamentos esperados de homens e
mulheres e são estimulados em crianças
ainda na infância eles dizem que não
maior poder ao homem gerando A Dominação
e consequentemente a violência contra a
mulher
e as mulheres são vítimas de diversos
tipos de abuso eles podem ser físicos
psicológicos sexuais Morais E
patrimoniais essas agressões são
cometidas por parceiros pelos amigos
familiares por instituições públicas ou
privadas e até mesmo pelo Estado diante
disso a universidade que deveria ser um
espaço de acolhida e crescimento
principalmente para os ingressantes se
torna o espaço que reforça as
desigualdades de gênero tornar um
ambiente fértil para violência contra
mulher eu preciso fazer um desabafo
e eu entrei na universidade em 2015 e as
seis anos eu vejo a violência contra
mulher dentro desses espaços Os relatos
Começam a surgir Logo no início do ano
letivo a narrativa é sempre a mesma e
muitas vezes agressores são os mesmos e
por isso e eu vejo pouca ou quase
nenhuma ação para tentar mudar esse
cenário com o tempo esse incômodo que
gerou em mim foi virando uma indignação
despertou em mim a vontade de mudar esse
cenário por isso em 2017 Eu comecei uma
pesquisa de iniciação científica dentro
desta temática que acabou virando meu
TCC anos mais tarde o meu objetivo nessa
pesquisa foi caracterizar a violência
contra a mulher e propor ações de
enfrentamento E para isso eu reuni a
narrativa de alunas vítimas de violência
nisso eu tive contato com dados e
Relatos alarmantes eles nos mostram a
crueldade da violência contra a mulher
embora duras eu preciso compartilhar
essas informações com vocês e
o que elas são muito importantes para
que vocês entendam a dimensão do
problema e também tendo as propostas de
enfrentamento que você tá mais adiante
é mas antes dos dados Eu quero fazer uma
reflexão eu acredito que todo mundo aqui
conhece a Lei Maria da Penha né O Nosso
principal mecanismo legal de prevenção
punição e inibição da violência contra a
mulher é vocês sabiam que a Lei Maria da
Penha de 2006 e além do feminicídio de
2015 gente quando eu entrei na
universidade não existia daí feminicídio
eu acredito que a maioria que tem mais
de 14 anos né quando nós temos não
existe a Lei Maria da Penha imagina esse
hoje em dia muitos crimes já ficam
impunes Imaginem na época essa situação
tá com o agressor era punido para que a
vítima era respeitada e acolhida
provavelmente não né partindo disso
e a gente percebe que os nossos poucos e
recém criados mecanismos legais não são
suficientes nós temos dados e Relatos
orais mãe mas hoje eu quero contar para
vocês a história da Maria nome Maria É
fictício faz a sua história é real A
Maria Era aluna do 1º ano da faculdade
ela tinha acabado de entrar na graduação
quando foi uma festa junto com seus
amigos essa festa com seu uma república
nessa festa a Maria conhecer um outro
aluno ele era veterano durante a festa
ele sabe que estava sempre perto da
Maria oferecendo bebida ele insistia
para que ela beber mesmo quando ela
recusava
e depois de um tempo esse aluno a chamou
para o quarto mas a Maria levou a Maria
continuava bêbada ele insistia para que
ela bebesse muito a Maria não tinha a
menor condição de consentir com nada mas
ela seguia negando e ele dizendo que não
faria nada que a Maria não quisesse
final do momento esse aluno levar Maria
para o quarto a força nessa noite a
Maria foi estuprada quando ela acordou
ele estava em cima dela ela pedia para
que ele parasse mas ele não parava
quando conseguiu Maria o empurrou e foi
embora Maria voltou para casa sozinha se
sentindo suja burra como se ela tivesse
a culpa pelos tu demorou muito tempo
para que a Maria conseguisse contar das
agressões para alguém quando conseguiu a
maioria dos seus amigos não ficarão
surpresas ele já conheciam a fama desse
agressor e eles deixaram a Maria aí para
o quarto com ele mesmo sabendo dessa
forma
e a Maria além de além dos seus amigos
Já saberem dessa fama eles ainda
colocaram a culpa do estupro nela
dizendo que ela que tinha bebido por
vontade própria o nome Maria É fictício
mas a sua história é real essa história
não é apenas da Maria Somos muitas
Marias Cada uma com a sua história mas
nós temos em comum a violência contra a
mulher e além de violentadas nós somos
silenciadas respeitadas e desacreditados
e
é uma pesquisa feita recentemente pelo
Instituto Avon mostra a dimensão do que
eu estou falando 56 por cento das
universitárias sofreram assédio sexual
dezoito por cento foram forçadas a
ingerir bebida alcoólica drogas ou a
parte a participar de atividades
degradantes 28 por cento sofreram
violência sexual tem que onze por cento
sofreram tentativa de estupro sob efeito
de álcool Quarenta e nove porcento das
universitárias sofreram de qualificação
intelectual e quando nós falamos de
agressões psicológicas 52 por cento das
universitárias sofreram abusos
psicológicos 24 por cento foram
colocadas em ranking sem autorização 14
por cento tiveram fotos íntimas vazadas
e 28 por cento já foram ofendidos e
xingados E além disso 25 porcento de a
se sentiram humilhadas e intimidados e
paralelo a esses números alarmantes não
poucos
só tem essas agressões apenas 26 por
cento dos homens admitiram terem
cometido o assédio sexual treze por
cento que cometeram violência sexual
doze por cento afirmaram terem praticado
o corção e apenas quatro porcento
concordaram que já agrediram fisicamente
uma mulher
ó E além disso 27 por cento dos homens
não consideram isto isto para abusar de
uma garota se ela estiver autorizada 31
por cento acham que não é violência
repassar fotos íntimas de uma mulher e
35% não conseguem violência com qual
gira uma mulher a participar de
atividades degradantes gente nós temos
56 por cento das universitárias vítimas
de assédio sexual mas apenas 26 por
cento dos homens admitem terem cometido
Tais atos os homens Ou eles não
acreditam nessas agressões ele não
reconhecem ou não assumem esses relatos
sobre a violência dentro do ambiente
Universitário nos mostram que
normalmente os agressores são ficantes
namorados amigos ou até mesmo
desconhecidos E essas agressões
acontecem em relações curtas mas os seus
danos são profundos e duradouros além
disso e por isso a gente precisa quebrar
essa crença de que a violência contra a
mulher sua
Eu também tô com a coabitação dentro
desse espaço Universitário a violência
tem várias Faces como trote os rankings
seus desfiles vexatórios e
frequentemente as agressões são
cometidas por alunos mais velhos em
relação a vítima mostrando aquela velha
relação de poder entre veteranos e
ingressantes e por isso as alunas do 1º
ano ficam mais expostas já que muitos
agressores agem Como se tivessem direito
seus corpos A gente observa além disso a
predominância da violência psicológica e
sexual isso acontece porque
historicamente a mulher é colocada como
submissão os desejos sexuais dos homens
e o abuso psicológico é uma consequência
de outras formas de agressão já que ela
gera uma ansiedade angústia o
afastamento dos amigos e familiares e aí
Justamente esse afastamento que torna a
vítima ainda mais vulnerável Porque
sozinha e desamparada ela não consegue
fazer a denúncia
é frequentemente a vítima sofre
violência mais de uma vez existe mais de
uma mulher sendo agredida dentro do
mesmo círculo de amigos Isso mostra que
muitas pessoas já conhecem os agressores
já que muitas vezes o agressor é o mesmo
e muitas pessoas ignoram esse fato e
esse calão muitas vezes para preservar a
identidade do agressor elas elas
desacreditam a vítima e menininhas
agressões Mas e você Você conhece alguém
que já cometeu violência contra mulher
algum conhecido seu de agredir uma
mulher se sim você o confrontou ou você
preferiu desacreditar a vítima a
história que eu contei isso acontece
muito sabiam das agressões anteriores
mas não contaram para vítima EA de
minimizar o seu sofrimento depois essas
atitudes nos mostram que muitas pessoas
acreditam que a violência contra a
mulher é aceitável isso ajuda a manter o
ciclo da violência e o único beneficiado
com isso é o próprio agressor
e a violência na universidade é velada
63 por cento das alunas não agrediram
quando foram agredidos não reagiram
quando foram agredidas e pouquíssimas
fizeram uma denúncia formal Existem
várias razões para que isso aconteça
como a ineficácia do nosso sistema ao
punir investigar os agressores o medo o
receio do agressor a esperança de
mudança além da manualização EA
normalização da violência contra a
mulher e muitos casos também a vítima só
percebe os abusos quando ela é agredida
fisicamente para que muitas formas de
violência não deixa marcas físicas como
a violência psicológica para denunciar a
vítima precisa quebrar Com todas essas
razões além de romper o ciclo da
violência e o ciclo da violência é
composto por três fases na primeira fase
a gente tem o aumento da tensão é onde o
agressor começa a demonstrar alguns
comportamentos agressivos a segunda fase
a gente tem a material materialização
toda essa tensão da primeira fase onde a
com
e a violência propriamente dita agressão
de fato e na terceira fase a gente tem é
chamada a lua de mel que quando o
agressor se diz arrependido da sua
violência e ele faz promessas para 21
que ele nunca mais falar nada daquilo e
o ciclo se repete de novo de novo e de
novo Muitas vezes a vítima não termina
com o agressor pelo medo ou pela crença
nas promessas do agressor a quebra no
ciclo muitas vezes acontece no contato
com a informação mas também do contato
com outras mulheres agredidas Por que
quando a vítima conhece a história de
outras mulheres ela percebe que ela não
está sozinha ela não é a única vítima da
violência contra mulher e uma mulher da
força para que a outra consiga romper
esse ciclo
E isso acontece e eu percebi numa
entrevista que eu fiz onde uma mulher
não me contou que ela percebeu a
violência e depois que a amiga dela foi
agredida e ela Conseguiu perceber que
ela não tava sozinho que ela podia
quebrar esse ciclo também dando amiga
dela deu força para que ela quebrar
saísse desse relacionamento abusivo os
dados sobre a violência contra a mulher
no ambiente Universitário chocam Mas
eles são necessários a Lei Maria da
Penha que eu comentei No começo é
importante por isso porque além de tudo
que ela promove ela ainda promove a
criação centro de referência EA
divulgação de informação e essa
informação precisa chegar correta e
efetivamente as mulheres precisam
conhecer os seus direitos a vítima
precisa de uma rede de apoio bem
preparada e disposta a ajudá-la é a
única forma da gente com pelo silêncio
da violência
é mas agora eu enfrentamento que eu
comentei no começo mas antes uma coisa
supondo que todos os anos chegam 2000
ingressantes em universidades aqui de
São Carlos sendo que sessenta e sete
porcento delas provavelmente será a
vítima de violência isso já resulta em
1340 mulheres sendo agredidas todos os
anos a universidade enquanto instituição
os seus coletivos e centros acadêmicos
precisam se posicionar vezes não é o
suficiente por isso agora eu proponho
que cada um pare agora e Pense nas ações
que podem tomar nesse enfrentamento à
violência contra a mulher mas eu pensei
em possíveis ações e vou compartilhar
com vocês hoje a primeira delas é muito
simples oferece ajuda se você conhece
uma mulher que está sendo agredida se
você perceber que uma mulher precisa de
apoio principalmente se ela estiver sob
efeito de álcool ou de drogas e se
alguém estiver tentando
Eu ofereci ajuda nesses casos se mostra
a disposição para ajudar essa mulher
você desconfiar que uma mulher está
sendo agredida converse com ela
novamente demonstre apoio e forme a
sobre os seus direitos e onde buscá-los
compartilhe com outras mulheres sobre
eventos e iniciativas que possam ajudar
em caso de violência informe-se sobre a
rede de apoio disponível na sua região
se você precisar encontrá-la será mais
fácil fale sobre a violência ao nos
calarmos nós estamos ajudando a manter
esse ciclo as discussões precisam ser
fundamentadas pare de culpar a vítima ou
menosprezar o seu sofrimento e pare de
passar quando para o seu amigo agressor
se você conhece uma mulher que quer
entrar ou já está na universidade
converse com ela sobre isso compartilhe
os dados mas desse 20 para ela a
violência contra a mulher na
universidade não é um problema Apenas da
vítima ou seu círculo de amigos mas é um
problema de
e a não fazermos nada nós estamos
beneficiando apenas o agressor você
conhece uma mulher que quer entrar na
universidade no próximo ano assim a
chance dela ser vítima de assédio sexual
é de quase sessenta por cento quantas
mulheres você vai deixar ser agredidas
por não ter dito nada sobre